we don't normally think about
foundational work as returning a value
on investment it's an unusual way to
look at it but it was really important
to make in terms of the numbers that you
bring out yeah well I think it's
important to say first of all about
Warren the most important thing bill and
I've learned from Warren are life
lessons even separate from money or you
know the the return on investment is
these life lessons that how you live
your life is really important and Warren
has a set of values that he's very true
to and lives to he loves to laugh and
make everybody feel good and so we feel
like as long as we've known him we've
been lucky because we learned by his
example and then this tremendous gift
that he gave to the foundation that you
know we weren't expecting to receive he
wasn't expecting to give right his his
money was going to go through the
foundation that has his wife's name on
it and she unfortunately passed away and
so when this gift came we were so
stunned by it and I think one of the
things that we realize is you feel a
responsibility to give your own wealth
thoughtfully but boy if it's somebody
else's well you really better do it in a
very careful and thoughtful way and and
so we do think about what's the return
on that and you know how many lives have
been saved have we done it in the best
possible way the most efficient way used
the best partners found the best
partners and I think Warne's really
inspired us in that way and the other
thing I'll say though is he does say I
don't want you to be risk free like I
want you to swing for the fences you're
taking on society's hardest problems
that are left behind so take risks swing
for the fences and so you know we've had
some failures along the way and Warren's
been okay with that because he knows
we're trying to move very difficult
problems forward we talked about
swinging off the fences and Livesay is
use the number of 122 million of
children's lives that have been saved
when the scale of that kind of gift came
in how much did you plan out how much
did it change the way you thought about
this scale and the impact of what you
could do yeah it well it had a
substantial effect on on the scale and
what we could do but the way we thought
about it when the gift came in is
you were already working in global
health we felt like we had gained some
knowledge understanding of the field
much much more to go believe me we're
learning organization we have so much to
learn and I hope we're learning
throughout our lifetime but we had
already gotten going on things like
vaccines malaria drugs working in
tuberculosis but when Warren's gift came
in we had another series of projects
these learning grants we were doing
because we were already saying to
ourselves it's phenomenal to people have
to start with a healthy life but it's
not enough like you've got to make sure
they have that healthy start in life you
know good basic health but then they've
got to be able to lift themselves out of
poverty right so we started a series of
grants and things like agriculture
because we know that's what's lifted
many many countries out of poverty is
his first agriculture and so we were
able to take Lauren's gift in and then
scale some of those anti-poverty
programs up like agriculture
substantially and much more quickly than
we probably would have otherwise I want
to talk about the central theme of the
letter this year which is really about
optimism and there's a line right at the
end that says the future will surprise
the pessimists when you look at what
you're doing and you look at the world
that we're in now some of the challenges
that we've faced some of the political
challenges that we face what gives you
cause for that kind of optimism runs
throughout in terms of the work you're
doing and where you see a better future
and a better global future perhaps most
importantly well you have to turn to to
the facts about what's happening you
know despite the things that people read
in the headlines about all the negative
news and there is negative news every
day but the world is getting better
poverty has been cut in half in half in
25 years you know we talk about the fact
that you know 122 million children are
alive because of this vaccine work
that's happened um and malaria bed nets
getting out there so it's it's both the
facts but then you know I've been lucky
enough I travel the developing world
three times a year and I'm not just
doing the government means I'm out in
remote rural dusty villages I'm out in
slums all the time and life is getting
better for people it's not getting
better fast enough bill and I are also
impatient optimists we want it to get
better
faster and we see things we have in the
US that if brought in the right way to
these countries people will take them up
and use them so but Eve but when I
travel even a place I've gone over and
over and over again this remote part of
Tanzania life is getting better farmers
are hooked up to markets they're selling
more eggs they're having more income
they're putting their kids in school so
it's not just palpable from the numbers
you have to look at the numbers to rely
on the facts but it's palpable when
you're out on the ground and I think
sometimes we forget that in the myriad
of issues that we face in our own lives
in our country